REPUBLICANS SETTING THE STAGE
FOR A LONG LIST OF
INVESTIGATIONS AGAINST PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
>> I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION OF JOE
BIDEN AND THAT'S WHERE THE
COMMITTEE WILL FOCUS IN THIS
NEXT CONGRESS.
>> INVESTIGATING PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS SOMETHING REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN PROMISING THEY'D DO, EVER
SINCE HE TOOK OFFICE.
>> IT'S NO SECRET THAT I'VE
INTRODUCED -- I THINK I'M UP TO
SIX ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT ON
JOE BIDEN.
>> IF WE DON'T ENGAGE IN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRIES TO GET THE
DOCUMENTS AND THE TESTIMONY AND
THE INFORMATION WE NEED, THEN I
BELIEVE THAT OUR VOTERS WILL
FEEL BETRAYED.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE UP ON
MY INVESTIGATION OF HUNTER
BIDEN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THERE YOU HEAR IT FROM SENATOR
GRASSLEY.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO JOE
BIDEN'S SON, HUNTER.
IT IS ONE OF THE TOP PROBES
REPUBLICANS ARE PROMISING
TONIGHT.
AND, IN FACT, IT IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT,
GOES ALL THE WAY BACK TO 2019
WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS JUST A
CANDIDATE.
THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP PRESSURED
UKRAINE AS PRESIDENT TO
INVESTIGATE HUNTER, WHO HAD
BUSINESS DEALINGS IN UKRAINE.
IT HAPPENED DURING A CALL ABOUT
AIDE TO UKRAINE, A CALL WHICH
YOU MAY REMEMBER BECAME THE
LINCHPIN OF THE FIRST
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IN A NEW PEW POLL AMERICANS
RANKED AN INVESTIGATION OF
HUNTER BIDEN AT 17 OF THINGS
IMPORTANT TO THEIR VOTE.
17.
AND YET REPUBLICANS TONIGHT ARE
STILL MOVING FULL STEAM AHEAD ON
THIS INVESTIGATION.
A MAJOR POWER PLAY AS THEY
PREPARE TO TAKE OVER THE HOUSE.
AND AS DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THEIR NEXT MOVE IN
CONGRESS AFTER THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE NANCY PELOSI ANNOUNCED
SHE'S STEPPING DOWN FROM HER
LEADERSHIP POST.
>> I WILL NOT SEEK REELECTION TO
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IN THE
NEXT CONGRESS.
FOR ME THE TIME HAS COME FOR A
NEW GENERATION TO LEAD THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THAT I SO
DEEPLY RESPECT.
I'M GRATEFUL THAT SO MANY ARE
READY AND WILLING TO SHOULDER
THIS AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY.
>> SARAH MURRAY BEGINS OUR
COVERAGE TONIGHT "OUTFRONT" IN
WASHINGTON.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEARNING ABOUT
PLANNED INVESTIGATIONS BY
REPUBLICANS?
>> REPUBLICANS MADE IT CLEAR
TODAY THEY JUST DOESN'T WANT TO
DIG INTO HUNT ER BIDEN.
THEY WANT THIS TO BE ABOUT
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING.
AFTER CLINCHING THE MAJORITY IN
THE U.S. HOUSE, GOP LAWMAKERS
ARE GEARING UP FOR THE SUBPOENA
POWER THEY'LL INHERIT IN
JANUARY, MANY AIMED AT PRESIDENT
BIDEN, HIS SON, HUNTER AND HIS
FAMILY'S BUSINESS DEALINGS.
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO
HUNTER AND JIM BIDEN.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE VOWING TO
FOCUS ON BANK RECORDS, KNOWN AS
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REPORTS OR
SARS FROM FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
AND RELATED TRANSACTIONS BY
BIDEN FAMILY MEMBERS.
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO PURSUE
SPECIFICALLY THE SARS AND BANK
RECORDS.
>> RED FLAGS WERE RAISED BY BANK
INDICATING SUSPICIOUS OR ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
>> Reporter: SUCH REPORTS ARE
NOT CONCLUSIVE AND DON'T
NECESSARILY INDICATE WRONG
DOING.
MILLIONS OF REPORTS ARE FILED
EACH YEAR AND FEW LEAD TO
INQUIRIES.
AND THERE ARE PLANS TO
INVESTIGATE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI.
>> WE ARE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
POLL
POLITICS OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT BASED ON THE FACT WE
HAVE HAD MORE THAN 14 WHISTLE
BLOWERS COME TALK TO US.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE REQUESTING
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REPORTS FROM
THE TREASURY, AND COMMUNICATIONS
FROM A FORMER HUNTER BIDEN
BUSINESS PARTER RELATED TO
HUNTER AND JOE BIDEN'S FINANCES,
TAXES AND DEBT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS REPEATEDLY
INSISTED HE HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH HIS SON'S OVERSEAS BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
AND IN A 2019 INTERVIEW, HUNTER
BIDEN ADMITTED TO POOR JUDGMENT
BUT NOT WRONG DOING WHEN IT CAME
TO HIS BUSINESS VENTURES.
>> I THINK IT WAS POOR JUDGMENT
ON MY PART.
DID I DO ANYTHING IMPROPER?
NO, NOT IN ANY WAY.
>> Reporter: A SPOKESMAN FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE OFFICE CALLED IT
POLITICAL REVENGE, CHOCKFUL OF
THEY HAVE NOT BROUGHT ANY
CHARGES IN THAT MATTER YET.
WE ALSO REACHED OUT TO PRIVATE
LAWYERS FOR BIDEN FAMILY MEMBERS
TODAY.
THEY DID NOT RESPOND BE TO OUR
REQUEST FOR COMMENT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AFTER SARAH'S REPORTING, LET'S
GO TO JERRY CONLEY OF VIRGINIA.
HE'S RUNNING TO BE THE TOP
DEMOCRAT ON THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
IT WOULD LEAD MANY OF THE BIDEN
INVESTIGATIONS.
CONGRESSMAN, THE INCOMING
REPUBLICAN OF YOUR COMMITTEE
SAYS THE FOCUS OF THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE INVESTIGATING JOE BIDEN.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> WELL, THIS IS A SHOP WORN
APPROACH BY THE REPUBLICANS ON
OUR COMMITTEE AND IT INVOLVES
SOME REALLY EXTRAORDINARY TOOLS
IN THE KICKBACK, INSINUATION,
FABRICATION, DISINFORMATION,
CONSPIRACY-BASED THEORIES THAT
GO NOWHERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
THE REPUBLICANS WHEN THEY WERE
IN THE MAJORITY, WHEN WE HAD
PRESIDENT OBAMA, TIME AND TIME
AGAIN THEY HAD HEADLINE GRABBING
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WENT
ABSOLUTELY NOWHERE.
BENGHAZI, THE IRS MANUFACTURED
SCANDAL ABOUT RIGHT WING FILTERS
AND NONPROFIT STATUS.
THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAILS.
ON AND ON AND NONE OF THEM
PRODUCED A THING EXCEPT
BREATHLESS HEADLINES THAT GAVE
THEM THE NARRATIVE THEY WANTED
AT THE TIME.
>> OF COURSE THERE'S ANOTHER WAY
TO LOOK AT THIS, WHEN DEMOCRATS
WON THE HOUSE IN 2018, RIGHT,
YOU ALL GOT CONTROL, MULTIPLE
COMMITTEES, INCLUDING THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE LAUNCHED
MULTIPLE INVESTIGATIONS INTO
TRUMP AND HIS ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK IT WAS SOMETHING LIKE 35
TOTAL.
13 IN YOUR COMMITTEE ALONE.
HOW IS THIS ANY DIFFERENT THAN
THAT?
>> I THINK THE PREMISE OF THAT
QUESTION REALLY HAS NO
EQUIVALENCE.
TO COMPARE JOE BIDEN TO DONALD
TRUMP EVEN ROBERT MULLER SAID HE
ENGAGED IN CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
WORTH FOLLOWING UP ON AND THERE
ARE MULTIPLE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS IN NEW YORK,
ATLANTA AND THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INVOLVING
HIS COMPANY, INVOLVING HIS
BEHAVIOR IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
INTERFERE WITH AND OVERTURN AN
ELECTION, HIS INCITEMENT OF AN
ELECTION.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
EQUIVALENCE BETWEEN THAT AND
WHETHER JOE BIDEN HAD A SON WHO
SHOWED GOOD OR BAD JUDGMENT.
>> SO SPEAKER PELOSI ANNOUNCED
AFTER BEING THE FIRST AND ONLY
WOMAN SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND
LEAD BEING DEMOCRATS FOR TWO
DECADES, SHE'S GOING TO STEP
DOWN.
IT'S TIME FOR A NEW GENERATION.
ONE NAME THAT IS HER LIKELY
SUCCESSOR IS CONGRESSMAN HAKEEM
JEFFERIES FROM THE STATE OF NEW
YORK?
DOES HE HAVE YOUR VOTE?
>> YES, HE DOES.
HE'S A MEASURED, TESTED, HIGHLY
SKILLED MEMBER.
I THINK HE CAN EASILY ENGENDER
THE TRUST ACROSS THE CAUCUS
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE SPECTRUM.
HE WILL SERVE ALL OF US VERY
WELL.
I THINK HE'S A SUPERB CHOICE TO
BEGIN TO FILL THE BIG SHOES OF
NANCY PELOSI.
>> NOW THOUGH IS THERE ANY WAY
IN THIS SITUATION, YOU GET A NEW
LEADER, CONGRESSMAN JEFFERIES
THEN THAT'S WHO IT WILL BE,
WHERE YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS GOING
DOWN ALL OF THESE INVESTIGATIVE
ROUTES THAT YOU AND THEY CAN
WORK TOGETHER ON ANYTHING?
IS IT POSSIBLE WHILE THEY'RE
INVESTIGATING HUNTER BIDEN THAT
YOU'RE ALSO PASSING LEGISLATION
TOGETHER?
>> YEAH, I THINK WE CAN CHEW GUM
AND WALK AT THE SAME TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO PUSH BACK ON WHAT
WE THINK ARE COMPLETELY
GROUNDLESS SO CALLED
INVESTIGATIONS WHICH ARE
DESIGNED FOR ONE PURPOSE TO
UNDERMINE THE LEGITIMACY OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IN TERMS OF COOPERATION, THE
INCOMING CHAIR OF OUR COMMITTEE,
WE WORKED WELL TOGETHER ON
POSTAL REFORM.
FEDERAL INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAM.
SO WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE A HISTORY
OF COOPERATION WHERE WE CAN FIND
COMMON GROUND AND WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO SEEK TO FIND COMMON
GROUND.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
CONGRESSMAN CONLEY.